critical matter we should address while
speaking
in terms of the interests of the
businesses and
how much they lose and that's
i think that's the thing that we should
take care about
because some businesses many actually
businesses
uh had very big expectations
about the month before the new year as
it usually is more profitable than
other months and they have to take this
into account
but the people are seeing what's
happening
you know many people are don't believe
in covets
no don't believe in code unless until
they catch it themselves
are you planning any lockdowns no we're
not planning a lockdown
actually i participated in the
tests of the gamalia sputnik v vaccine
and unfortunately i was met
with with certain people
who were not very understanding of why i
did that
well you have to explain it to them but
how
can we motivate and encourage
people to vaccinate themselves
deliberately because if they don't this
will take a lot of time i can only say
that this
has to be voluntary this can only be
voluntary and there's for encouraging
people to
take the short this is your work you as
a journalist as a responsible individual
need to bring to the people this
information
so that they are that they trusts you
and then trusts the the fact that their
vaccine is important and making
having a shot as important what is it
that you're writing
in your notebooks all the time uh these
are just
some scribbles about who's asking what
the names the specific topics
okay you know see this new start
treaty the name olga parts of the
questions i'm answered just to remember
them
are you going to to address
certain issues with the
specific governors yes we after
after all this is recorded we will deal
with everything that has been talked
about
is this tea no this is a brew of uh
siberian herbs yes it's uh from siberia
herbs from siberia yes nothing much
are you going to miss miss merkel
well well she's not going anywhere yet
she's still working
i don't think it would be correct of me
to
speak about her in the past tense she
germany is a parliamentary democracy and
i understand what's happening
there domestically in germany
the internal politics
myself and ms merkel have rather warm
relations and
and our two countries also have very
good relations
germany is one of our largest economic
partners
trade partners i think it's
second after china
in terms of
certain that german interpreters are one
of the
largest investors into russian economies
unlike many other investors german
entrepreneurs invest
into the real physical sector into real
production
and industry in russia
what do you expect of your relations
with the new
u.s administration with mr biden well
that depends on the administration
itself
mr biden is an experienced person
but like they say it is the
king's surrounding that make the king so
we need to know all the people that are
going to work with us
all the people in the administration
although most of them we have met before
we have worked with them before
so we don't expect any surprises
you must have heard the statement by mr
biden about
it's being reasonable to extend the new
start treaty which expires in february
which is a good thing
mr president can you guarantee that
well that's not formulated with such
words
we've had certain strict restrictions
last spring
are we going to expect any more
similar restrictions coming next year
no not at all yes the
the rate of infection is quite high but
it certainly reached a plateau
and it's not going up by much
we have enough hospital beds we have
enough
medicine and equipment and ppe's
to help the people and we will continue
to monitor the situation so that
everyone receives the medicine they need
so that people are hospitalized
when it has to be done
but like you said some people don't
believe in anything and
don't want to receive the
the shot against the coronavirus while
others are complaining that they're not
taking
care of not taken to the hospital
so i believe that we need to continue to
work steadily
and
and observe the rules and
continue to do what the doctors are
asking of us that we won't ever need a
lockdown
anymore
you spoke about my colleague
that he has been working that he's been
blamed for that that the charges against
him
are because he has been working in the
russian space agency
no why i wasn't talking about that the
charges against him have nothing to do
with his work in the commerce and
newspaper but it has to do
with the long period of time when he
worked with mr rogozin who's the head of
the russian space agency
that's what i meant
he has worked in many other places
we need the investigation the
investigators
to tackle to handle this
this issue
he wasn't a journalist who accused some
high-ranking person of anything
and that's why someone puts
a bounty on his head so to speak of
course not it's not like that
the issue is is what he's
charged with true did he indeed commit
any crimes
specifically providing western
intelligence agencies
with the classified rush information
that's the charge
i cannot go into more details because
this is a very delicate matter
the investigators will deal with that
but this person he doesn't have
any enemies
he's been working in the media sphere in
the information sphere
and he deliberately gave
some classified sensitive information to
western
intelligence as a journalist
some agreement with a western media
but that has nothing to do with the fact
that he gave classified
information to someone else he was
collecting this information deliberately
that's that's very different from him
just interacting with western media
that's it there's no conspiracy there
maybe it's true it goes into something
now of course
nonsense regardless is not pressuring
anyone
he's just
he's just a civil servant he's if he's
doing his work properly
he'll stay if he's not we'll replace him
with someone
there are no conspiracies here it's
nonsense
don't think about it i understand that
many of your colleagues knew him
personally
but what can i what can you do about it
he deliberately knowingly
gave classified information to the
western intelligence
and that's the that's what he being
accused of
and it's the prosecutors who have to
prove that if they do then well he will
be punished if not he'll be
he'll be free
so we will spoke about the benefits
to the children to the parents with
children that's what we've done before
the end of the year yes before the end
of the year like like before
happy new year yes happy new year
thank you thank you so much
you